les maires en moi c'est comme disent à
chaque fois c'est la loi et nous disons
clairement nous ne voulons plus de loi
qui complique l'action locale nous en
avons assez
les maires de côte-d'or face à leurs
d'écouté sur scène il écoute les
attentes vraie inquiétude des calculs
200 mères ayant fait le déplacement que
des échanges parfois vifs les sujets ne
manquent pas semaine de quatre jours
réforme territoriale possible
exonération de la taxe d'habitation pour
80 % des contribuables
les maires sont inquiets et manque de
moyens en quatre ans le montant de leurs
dotations a baissé de 30%
on arrive à faire du fonctionnement
c'est tout n'est pas question de faire
de l'investissement alors le problème il
alla donc plus d'investissements plus de
travail pour les entreprises locales
il ya eu du personnel comme même
d'embaucher et si on revient donc aux
quatre jours qu'est ce qu'on va faire
donc de ce personnel des 28000 euros
effectivement napo c'est si mathieu
mille euros d'impôts je sais pas je ne
pourrai plus faire d'investissements
gérés pub possibilité de terrain quoique
investissement
je ne peux rien faire mais les taxes
d'habitation au jour d'aujourd'hui chez
nous c'est primordial pas une première
rencontre officielle en groupe est une
nécessité pour le président de
l'association des maires de côte-d'or
nous renforcer les liens avec ceux qui
écrivent les lois on a vraiment une
attente de retour du travail à
l'assemblée nationale de la part de nos
députés
il ya des annonces qui
interroge et là on vu un travail
constructif régulier pour qu' il n'y a
pas de réforme comme les précédentes
qu'on a subies et qu'on subit encore
aujourd'hui se faire entendre jusque
dans l'hémicycle
c'est en tout cas ce qu'espèrent les
maires côte-d'oriens en autres
rassemblements comme celui ci devrait
avoir lieu l'année prochaine